la chambre de métiers de l'artisanat de
l'essonne défend et accompagne les
entreprises artisanales de notre
département
l'idée originale de notre série artisan
d'un jour et de glisser un élu du
territoire dans la peau d'un artisan
afin qu'ils comprennent mieux son métier
et ses préoccupations découvrons
ensemble notre artisan d'un jour
françois durr vrai je suis présidente du
conseil départemental de l'essonne
depuis avril ou 2015
le département de l'essonne c'est 1,3
million d'habitants
le conseil départemental veut aider
pleinement le monde de l'entreprise et
de l'artisanat et c'est à ce titre que
j'ai eu le plaisir de répondre
favorablement à l'invitation d'artisans
dangereux
l'avenue président je ne vous présente
pas françois durovray que vous
connaissez que vous allez accompagner
pour qu'ils découvrent les facettes de
votre métier
c'est une petite entreprise avec quand
même douze salariés
on a plusieurs sortes de pains départ à
grain des pins à base de seigle défunt à
base du complet tout est fait chez nous
le moindre petit décor est fabriqué sur
place les ses créations c'est vous c'est
la survie c'est vous bonjour monsieur je
débute tout juste
je mets dans le plat et ensuite je
prends la voilà le prend et cette forme
et je tourne comme ça voilà voilà un bus
coup tranchée à oreille aux cinq
personnes à la vente mais j'ai deux
apprentis cette année
tout le monde la fonction de l'amplitude
horaire angeles lakers et pas forcément
évident aujourd'hui oui par rapport à
quelques années c'est vraiment compliqué
à gérer d'une grande entreprise ya
beaucoup de salariés donc ont besoin
voilà mille à cinq nous il faut pas
qu'ils ne soient pas là et il faut pas
qu'il y en ait une qui soit malade
aujourd'hui je pense qu'on n'est pas
assez valorisé on vous écoute pas aussi
dans notre vie du quotidien et c'est
pour ça que j'étais contente de vous
accueillir et on n'est pas là pour se
plaindre
d'accord on va bien la seule chose qui
me rend qui m'attriste en fait c'est je
n'arrive plus à faire mon métier
correctement
c'est à dire de zoologie d'être ici on
est envahi par les normes par la
réglementation moi je suis passionné moi
j'adore ce que je fais je transmette
c'est puis à voir le sourire des gens
quand ils viennent ils nous disent on a
passé un super moment
maintenant je vais vous amener à un
endroit est très important c'est la
production la fabrication je vous laisse
ma compagnie
et si on l atelier faut retrousser les
manches voilà on va commencer par le
début par le façonnage 1 le façonnage
c'est quoi le façonnage alors le
façonnage c'est la mise en forme des
pâtons de vagues est une tradition c'est
pas facile à prendre parce que ouais bah
c'est un métier un c'est beaucoup plus
souple que j'ai imaginé ça y est j'ai
commencé à mieux elle est déjà nettement
mieux par rapport à tout ça ça peut pas
être mécanique
c'est pour ça que ça reste de
l'artisanat
moi ce que je retiens c'est qu'il ya une
question de temps à chaque fois d'abord
ce sont des gestes très précis mais il
ya un moment où il faut donner du temps
et notamment donner du temps la matière
est ce que je retiens aussi c'est la
précision des gestes mais la rapidité
des gestes walla africable vous aurez le
droit de revenir demain
c est la question que j'allais vous
posez il faut y aller franchement
d'accord si je fais tout doucement ça va
pas aller je le tiens au début et après
givet franchement tient pas à la la
c'est mieux ce qui m'a fait plaisir s'il
m'a beaucoup ému temps avec sandrine
qu'avec lionel c'est de voir la passion
de ces gens pour leur métier ils ont
accepté je crois de m'accueillir ce
matin est sage et les ressentis dès le
départ parce qu'ils ont envie de
transmettre et que c'est un métier où
évidemment et je crois que c'est le cas
de tous les métiers d'artisanat
on doit transmettre il ya du boulot au
niveau de la formation pour les
apprentis et ça c'est un enjeu pour vous
vous lorsque vous accueillez un apprenti
dès la première semaine vous faites un
peu comme vous l'avez fait avec moi avec
vous dès les premiers gestes qui seront
les gestes de toute la vie
professionnelle la responsabilité des
collectifs quand même elle est au niveau
de l'école mais elle est aussi au niveau
des patrons et si aujourd'hui on ne
forme pas demain
mais thierrens part belle aux métiers
verts dispagne moi ce que je vois c'est
que c'est une en boutique comme ici il
ya un chef c'est très organisé tout est
minuté
chacun à sa place c'est une petite
entreprise mais c'est l'addition toutes
ces petites entreprises qui font
l'artisanat y qui font que c'est là
aujourd'hui la première entreprise de
france l'artisanat merci non merci c'est
une super expérience et moi j'ai proposé
à sandrine devenir l uimm elle aussi
devenir me suivre département pour voir
ce que c'est la vie d'un élu sur une
journée
et